You don't know much. I'm just being
honest because say
>> your interpretation is your own
interpretation.
>> So why are we talking man? You don't
know. Every time something you're going
to say you don't know. Why don't you go
sleep or do f by the way when you do
faja? Do you flush water in and out of
your nose three times?
>> Yeah.
>> Like when you do woo for fajger prayer
morning prayer.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Three times. Right. You and your
husband.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. So,
>> everyone everyone who does uh who does
the vouch you and your husband. So, when
you're about to do faj morning prayer,
you have to do woo and you put water in
and out of your nose three times. You
and your husband. Do you know why you
and your husband do that?
>> Not just me and my husband, but every
single person does a lot of snack
bottle. I know. But do you know why you
guys are doing it when you pray?
>> To clean out our nose.
>> No, because Muhammad said to flush Satan
out of your nose because he sleeps in
your nose.
That's one. Okay, that's even more
deeper. That's that's more deeper. I do
believe that
>> I gave you a very basic thing.
Do
>> you believe basic explanation, but there
are not just this or just for cleansing?
There are so many benefits.
>> That's not my question. Do you believe
>> many benefits in cleaning your nose and
>> No, the benefit is for flushing out your
nose. Here it is. Here it is. Okay.
Narrated Aisha, I'm sorry, Abu Hara, the
prophet said, "If any one of you rouses
from sleep and performs evolution, he
should wash his nose by putting water in
it and then blowing it out thrice
because Satan has stayed in the upper
part of his nose all the night." Okay.
And this is Sal Bkari. Let me get you
the link from sunna.com. Here's the
link. Sal Bkari, volume 4, book 54,
Hadith five. Man, my eye besides bad.
Let me see. 16. Here it is the link. So
you don't think I'm lying. So Muhammad
said that's why you do it because you
got to flush Satan out of your nose. So
is Satan in your husband's nose?
>> Okay, what's the point?
>> Because okay, how many noses does Satan
live in? Because if you're flushing him
out of your nose and your husband's
flushing out of his nose, that means
he's in your nose and his nose at the
same time. How is that possible?
>> How is it possible? Because Satan is a
um a form of uh I don't know exactly
what form it is but Satan is with almost
everyone leading into evil.
>> So Satan is omnipresent huh? Wow. Even
your God is not omnipresent but Satan
is. Huh?
>> God is always present, always watching.
And and you know why And you know,
right? And you know why Satan is sent,
right? And you know why Satan is there.
point.
>> Can you make my point? I didn't say
Allah is watching. I know you believe
he's watching. I didn't say that. Satan,
unlike Allah, is with you and your
husband and all the Muslim noses at the
same time. So, he's here in your noses,
all of you. Even Allah is not with you
the way Satan is. So, how can Satan be
with all of you
>> in your noses physically? Something that
Allah doesn't do.
>> That's not right. That's not right. What
your statement is not right because
Allah Allah is with you whenever you
are.
>> So is Allah physically with you like
saints physically in your nose?
>> Physically
seriously
Allah so small that he is my water
physical
is Allah so small that he can get into
my nose.
>> But wait, Satan is so big he can fit in
all of your noses at the same time.
>> Satan's form is different. Do you know
what's the form of Satan?
>> I don't want to find out. But you should
because he's in your nose right now.
>> I don't know either because that's
>> But he's in your nose right now. Did you
>> the unseen? But okay.
>> No, no, no. You gave me only the the
knowledge of the unseen. I know what you
said.
>> Give me the meaning of
means knowledge of the unseen. I just
told
>> Okay, good. Okay, good.
>> I know it is. But before you go on, be
patient.
Satan's in your nose right now. Do you
know that? Right.
>> I don't know.
>> Yeah. Your prophet just said that when
you perform faj you have to flush water
in and out of your nose because Satan
stays there overnight. It's now
overnight. It's night where you're at,
right?
>> Um say Okay. So
>> So he's in your nose. Did you flush him
out?
>> Okay. Satan.
>> Did you flush him out? Because maybe
that's why you're having a hard time
understanding me because Satan's in your
nose occupying himself. confusing you.
That's why you can't understand. So, is
he in your nose right now? Did you flush
him out? Go flush him out. Maybe you can
>> Satan. Satan is not in my nose as long
as I remember Allah subhanahu wa tala.
>> That's not what Muhammad said. Muhammad
said he's there in your nose until you
flush him out before faj prayer.
>> He he he does not he did not say that
he's always there.
>> Did he say that?
>> Are you adding to the words of your
prophet?
>> Did he say that in that hadith? It will
that's why yes if it's in that hadith
means that if there is sat Satan if
>> yes that's why you have to flush water
in and out of your nose every morning
because he's there well then why do you
do it every morning
>> if there is if there is
>> he didn't say if get stuck for Allah how
dare you no
Satan is not with anyone who remembers
him the remembrance of Allah will keep
Satan away
>> are you sure very sure
>> you positive
>> very positive
>> so then why do you have to then flush
water in and out of your nose in the
morning if
>> at all if at all there is Satan
>> okay now another question I want to ask
you uh when the call to prayer adan is
made it says Satan farts he likes to
fart so he doesn't hear the call to
prayer so does Satan fart really does he
blow winds and if he does how nasty is
the smell of his farts
What? I haven't heard this. Say that
again.
>> Hold on. Let me give it to you. Yeah,
it's your prophet said that when there's
a call to prayer, the adan, Satan blows
wind, farts so loud so he doesn't hear
it and he takes off.
So I want to know here. Let me You're
laughing at your prophet. Here it is,
man. How are you laughing at your
prophet? Here you go. Bkari.
>> I'm not. That's
your own way of describing it. here.
>> I'm not I'm not laughing at my beloved
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him.
That's your way of describing buddy.
>> Okay, [laughter]
let me read it for you.
You make me laugh, I swear. Okay,
Allah's messenger said,
"When the adan is pronounced, Satan
takes his eels and he passes wind."
So he farts. Passes wind. He farts with
noise, a loud fart
during his flight in order not to hear
the adan. This is Sal Bkari Bkari. Then
he comes back when the adan is finished.
Volume one, Hadith 582. So not only does
he fart, it says with noise. So that
>> where does it say it farts?
>> What do you think the word passes when
means in Arabic?
This is your interpretation Sam.
>> Okay. So what is passing wind? He blows.
He whispers.
>> That's
that passes wind might have other
meanings too.
>> The word means he farts.
>> You can you can take any meaning out of
your own desire.
>> Arabic means he farts and he farts loud.
Okay. So does is this fart does it smell
is it does it smell as bad as my farts
when I'm drinking protein shakes?
I don't want to I don't want to talk on
this uh indecent. No,
>> wait. I'm quoting the sunnah of your
prophet. This is Muhammad. Why are you
ashamed of the sunnah? Stuck for Allah
gets it.
>> It says passes wind. Passes wind does
not mean farts.
>> It's not always doesn't always mean fart
saying.
>> Oh, so you mean he's going he's just
passing by going [snorts]
>> I don't know.
>> Okay. All right. Now, has there been
times where you haven't woken up for
morning prayer? Faja? Very few times.
>> Very few times. All right. Do you know
why you didn't wake up for faja?
>> Shaitan.
>> Shayan. Why? You know how didan
>> because I listened to shaitan.
>> No, because he pissed in your ears.
>> No, because I I listen to shaitan.
Shayan said, "You know what? You're so
tired. Don't wake up. It's okay if you
don't."
>> No, it's because he pissed in your ears.
>> He He whispers in he he whispers in my
ears. That's what you interpret as
pisses in your ear.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> This is the sunnah of your prophet. It
says here it is bkari. There's the link.
I'm going to send in private chat. It
says a man did not wake up for faj
prayer. He didn't hear the call to adan
because Satan pissed in his ears. Was
pissing in his ears. Here it is. So you
didn't get up because that time
>> is is that a story like an event
happened or
>> narrated? Is it like
>> narrated Abdah? I'm reading the hadith.
Narrated Abdullah. It was mentioned
before the prophet that there was a man
who slept the night till morning after
sunrise. The prophet said he's a man in
whose ears or ears Satan had urinated.
So Satan pissed in his ears. So did
Satan piss in your ears? Is that why you
didn't get up?
>> Satan whispered into me saying that
you're so tired. Don't don't up. It's
okay to not pray fudger.
I didn't pray.
He didn't piss in your ears?
>> No, I don't think so.
>> So, but but he did piss in this man's
ears. So, you're okay with Satan? He
pisses. He takes a leak. He farts. He
stays in your nose. You're okay with
that? That Well, your prophet said this
about Satan. So, when Satan pisses, is
the color of his urine white or yellow?
[laughter]
If Satan is not human,
how can a urine be a yellow or a white?
>> Oh, so then what color is it? It's the
person in his ear.
>> Sam, your logic is so so so naive. Trust
me.
>> I'm just telling you. I'm reading the
>> You're so naive.
Trust me.
>> I'm just reading the Satan is not Sat
Satan is not at all in human form. And
if And you're asking if his urine is in
yellow or
>> well your prophet said he pisses. So
then how does he piss?
>> That's